In a February Gallup poll, 72% of
Americans viewed Russia unfavorably. This
is the highest negative rating in three
decades. Americans clearly believe that
Russia tried to interfere in the 2016 US
election. In January and March Quinnipiac
University surveys, around 70% of
registered voters said that it did.
People want the Russia investigation to
continue, and most people feel confident
that Special Counsel Robert Muller will
conduct a fair investigation. In three
identically worded questions asked by
Pew from November through early March,
between 55% and 61% felt confident.
Looking forward, Americans are concerned
about the November 2018 elections. In a
new Marist Poll, 51% said
that it was likely that there would be
Russian interference in them. 41%
said it was not very or not likely at
all. And they want President Trump to do
more. In the March Quinnipiac University
poll, 61% of registered voters said that
the Trump administration should be doing
more to protect the elections from Russian interference.
What do you think
about the Russia investigation? Let us
know in your comments. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.